I forgive you only and his mother
the person who killed him really killed
him I'm not going to revenge against you
forgiveness is the greatest gift
or charity in Islam
I have to pour myself out to forgive
someone this
I have wronged our family
[Music]
foreign
with the hard work of Eddie this is more
than just a Masjid that's being built
this is more than just another dawa
Center yeah so we transforming this from
people worshiping the creation to
worshiping the Creator Allah bless your
efforts Eddie
there's a police officer now reacting to
uh the Muslim forgiving
uh one I think it was something for
every parent to see and how fortunate
these young men are to have such a role
model and a father and a leader in a
community that actually
gives guidance and a path and I think
that's what we saw in this we had two
really good families that came together
that did not know each other over some
tragedy
we spoke yesterday when we came in from
Thailand we had lunch and we were
thankful for one thing it's such a
horrific tragedy brought it so close as
friends
of being with each other
[Music]
[Applause]
let me interchange
and his final message
[Music]
foreign
so we got to see now it's the Blessed
month in Ramadan it's the month of mercy
and forgiveness and this is a story that
hit while back where father
he was now brought in front of a
perpetrator a person that ended up
luring his son along with some others I
believe into an apartment they robbed
him killed him and now you can see now
he didn't technically have to forgive
him islamically right but he went to a
whole nother level he did yeah so I
wanted to contrast this with uh and we
can go ahead and talk because on that
topic of mercy and forgiveness because a
lot of times if we look at this and then
we compare it because you're also a
counselor you're somebody who deals with
many family issues and back and forth
how does this compare to some of the
stories that you hear and you look back
and say wow you're really gonna let
Shakedown divide you guys like this and
not forgive comparing to some something
like this at a whole other level indeed
indeed Allah
foreign
was sent as a mercy to the universe and
he is the mercy
that Mercy is our role model
and if you believe in Allah in the last
day Allah says and it's easy said than
done
easier said than done huh indeed I could
see you got a little bit watery eyed I
do I do I mean that's where really
it requires us to step up come out of
our comfort zone and our own personal
interest
and be the True Believer and the um
in that video clip that in itself
that shows that any father any parent
would find justifiable to take the life
of the person who murdered their own
child
but what caused that person to forgive
that individual
it's not his own personality or his
culture background his values rather he
said that this is what Allah wants from
me so it's the teaching of Islam
sponsored by Islam because of his
because what he knows about Allah Allah
and he is clearly stating that although
I want to I can take the Revenge but
this is what Allah demands this from me
this is
demonstrated and as a follower and a
believer in Allah
I will do what has asked of me no matter
how difficult it is and it is this
moment Allah when the Believers apply
these teachings of rasulullah convert
that very act and act of dawa an
invitation to Islam and that is the
nobility of Islam that is the true
Essence that you see of belief in Allah
and taking me as a role model
it's easy to follow Islam when it is
convenience to you
where you get tested is that when it
goes totally against you nothing really
serves your interest and you still put
above your interest the obedience to
Allah and this was a fine example this
was a fine example and what other thing
that I wanted to point out in that video
was when he forgive and he met with the
murderer of his son and gave him hug
that is humanity in real essence
away from hate any
grudges
any influence of evil and devil
that which Allah has created us with
this nature of understanding and
forgiving and putting our goal for
success in the year after and ultimately
pleasure of Allah so this is at a whole
different level of a grand stage now
people non-muslims are getting to see
Islam in action like at a whole
different level because he's quoting the
Quran he's showing that this is like the
mercy of Islam that he's uh
he's portraying and many of us not going
to reach that level here but
you can reach this level somewhat if now
maybe you can forgive someone in your
immediate family because are you we're
seeing like from year to year Ramadan to
Ramadan we got brother not speaking to
brother sister not speaking his sister
you got uh
father and son daughter and mother
Anthony you got all these different
family units and now they're not talking
and the one stubbornly refuses to he's
holding on to a grudge holding on to the
Past doesn't want to let it go
and now you you're not being called to
forgive the murder of your family you're
not right it's just forgiveness of the
hard feelings or misunderstanding most
of the time
and trust me Eddie you know this video
is not of the ancient time and we are
not even talking about the time of the
stories of the prophets
this is not something from a long time
ago yeah people very easily and
conveniently say that oh he was a
prophet oh those were companions they
had the blessings of Allah's presence
they were able to do that we live in
this time and age is difficult you don't
know what my situation is you don't know
how hurt I am you don't know how wrong I
have been by these people how could I
ever forgive I will never forgive them
in million years these are the statement
that I get in my counseling people are
saying this I will never forgive I will
never forgive this word never forgive is
very common when it comes to disputes
and they even reference saying that in
this time and age they're doing this
this video is not from far it is
happening right here and if that fellow
can really rise above all of these
challenges and temptations that you and
I are going through and still find a way
to obey Allah and rasulullah and do what
is right only because he's been asked to
do whether it makes sense or not that's
what can become the huja against us in
the day of judgment it is people like
these we should be afraid of because if
they can do it Allah may ask in the day
of judgment why can't you if he was
wrong so much so that his son was taken
away from him what was wrong with you
what have you lost your feelings were
hurt
yes I understand that even then Islam is
demanding for you to come out and
forgive for the sake of Allah
and all in all if you understand
let's not talk about religion let's not
talk about being kind and nice person
let me talk in that emotion aspect of it
as a human being
I have asked many times when people hold
grudges and difficult movements
remembers them so quick vividly when you
talk to them and they talk to you they
literally you could see in their eyes
they're seeing that is happening in
front of them
and without any control their tears
begin to flow from their eyes that tells
you how hurt they are there is no
denying as the counselor I sit over
there I pass them the tissue box clearly
you know and let them wipe their tears
without even them realizing
they are in totally different mode you
could see that they're sitting in front
of you they're not present because they
are present in the moment when they had
that heated argument or the hurt that
they suffer and that caused that pain
suffering that they feel they're feeling
at that very moment
I let them have this episode
and when they calm down a little bit
then I ask them how long ago has it
happened
and they tell me years past
years years has passed and I say wait
that individual that had caused you this
pain
and they just smiled they said they're
just living their life happily
I say what are you doing to yourself
do you actually harm me yourself more
they harm you once and you're harming
yourself again and again again and again
again and again when each time you
remember that moment
you're doing zoom on yourself
and that is a transgression against your
own self and the first and foremost the
person who benefits for forgiveness is
your own self you liberate yourself from
that hate and pain and suffering so
Allah intend that ease for you Allah
does not intend difficulty for you when
he asks you to forgive forgive for the
sake of Allah Allah says you know Allah
does not benefit your with your
forgiveness to the other human beings
but Allah is saying forgive for my sake
it is the kindness and the generosity of
Allah saying that all right unload all
of your pain and suffering onto me I'll
take care of it I want you to live your
life peacefully as long as I have degree
for you to walk on this Earth so my
beloved as a believer
as a Believer it is to your good
advantage that you forgive for the sake
of Allah because Allah loves you so much
that you want to liberate you from that
pain and suffering and you can live and
no sooner that I guide people to forgive
each other and when they Embrace and
accept in the light of Quran and Sunnah
before even they move from their chairs
I ask them how do you feel
you know most of the time the response
is
I feel very light
they were carrying this burden like a
Rocky Mountain Himalaya Mountain burden
on their heart and that is why they were
very teary no sooner that they hear or
remember of something like this their
tears flow from their eyes but this is
no longer the case the person right away
is benefiting themselves constantly as a
human being you benefit
through the same
your benefit is manifold
one you liberate yourself from this pain
and suffering and the way that you
carries all your life and we're heavy on
your emotion and your decision making it
literally literally influence and
affects your lifestyle on the current on
the contrary doesn't it in in a negative
way not only influence you but let's say
we're particularly talking about like
family now like we have the family of
the ummah but now you have family blood
family okay and now you have uh people
who are within their family if they're
not setting a good example now you have
kids coming along have you seen like
generations of generations now the kid
kids kind of inherit this meaning that
now they end up holding a grudge because
there may be father held the garage or
to sit there held the girl and then they
start creating uh a resentment between a
certain family member because a certain
family didn't let it go true
let me continue on the point that and
then I will answer that question first
as a human being you'll benefit by
letting go of these gorges and if you do
it for the sake of Allah as a Believer
your reward multiplies you enjoy the
benefit as a human being for letting go
of The Grudges and you also enjoy the
reward from Allah because you did so
Hall is
so it's a win-win situation as a
Believer so While others are doing it
for their own reasons you ought to do as
a Believer because your Rob has demanded
this from you so with that great
incentive Muslims should be the first
and foremost to forgive anyone for any
crime any sin or any hurt any pain that
they have caused second and if you don't
do this
if you do this you're winning in your
life and the Hereafter also but if you
refuse to do this in spite of having
great incentive given to you the
consequences are severe
cutting the ties now you're talking
about the humanity we were talking about
killing somebody random person causing
any hurt and pain to you talk about this
is happening from your own family member
immediate family members be it is your
spouse be it is your in-laws be it is
your relatives be it is your children
sometimes even parents and some I have
seen Asian parents having this kind of
pain and suffering from their children
in all in all this is the play of
shaitaan
shaytan tried to create this kind of
environment so they cannot be at the
peace when they're worshiping Allah
so we have got to turn to Allah seeking
Refuge from this situation but the
consequences of not doing it are the
following
one
when the two individuals have this
situation
and precise on this saying that if you
have differences with a fellow Muslim
you have to reconcile within three days
if not then you will find your place in
the Hellfire it's a strong statement
this will affect only those individuals
who truly believe in heaven and hell
truly appreciate what really happens in
Hell Fire
and only then and then only they'll be
able to understand and compare between
holding this position of this haters
towards each other or letting go for the
sake of Allah for the fear of being put
into the Hellfire that is what
rasulullah wanted to convey he is Mercy
for the universe he loves us very much
and he does not want us to enter into
the Hell Fire so he's pointing out to
that thing he's saying that if you don't
that is your board so I ask you to
forgive for the sake of Allah if you
don't do this and look the picture that
Allah had in front of him just pictures
I'm talking to the sahaba
advising them on kinship and the family
values and relationship and knowing the
challenges that they're going through
even then encouraging them to forgive
why
in Islam family structure is one of the
greatest Foundation that Islam is built
on
and this kind of differences causes
family to fall apart and when that
happened the Islam is compromised in the
practice of individual's life so
therefore it is very important The
Grudges when the parents individuals
hold against each other from the
relatives get transmitted into the
family members kids you talk about very
beautifully who suffer
kids suffer silently
they don't even know at times reason why
the adults have fought
they even question if my mom or dad has
problem with each other or within laws
with Aunt or uncles or with that cousin
of mine why should I be prohibited from
meeting and talking to their children
how should I behave when they come
across
how should I be able to give them Salam
or not these are the questions that I
get asked as a Imam in the Masjid
people are asking we come to pray we are
cousins in the same Masjid
but we can't say Islam to each other
because our parents are not in good
terms with each other
who is responsible for this
now that's that's something you're
passing down instead of passing down
these good teachings and forgiveness
of things that are pleasing to Allah it
reminds me of the Hadith where the the
prophet saws had talked about if you
expect Allah's Mercy
then you need to go ahead and I mean
because you got a lot to account for
also right yes and you don't want to be
held up on a day of judgment pulled over
to the side and questioned about all of
the sins
anyone who don't
show Mercy to Mankind
don't expect that from Allah
and you want Allah to forgive
forgive his creation
what a beautiful teachings what a
beautiful teaching how do you know if
you've if you've truly forgiven I just
recorded a video clip for one of the TV
channel
where they talk they asked me the same
question how do you know
I said this is the Blessed month of
Ramadan
each ramazan said to go into fasting day
set a goal
look into individuals who you don't like
and have been the source of your parents
suffering
identify those individuals with their
name create a list if you must
and pray for them first without even
talking to them pray for them make Dua
for them
forgive them and
because forgiving
is easy
but making Dua for that individual
it's a challenge to your belief
and that's where you can rise above if
you truly want to forgive somebody
and if you can go a step further
then I encourage you to send that
individual a gift
let that individual know on a simple
message
you may agree or not whether you approve
of this or not whether you like it or
not I just want you to know from my side
I have forgiven you for the pain
suffering that you had caused me and I
pray to Allah that Allah keep you on the
right path in me and I ask you to
forgive me
these are the steps that need to be
taken and once again I said it's easy
said than done
but if you have trust in Allah and if
you take rasulullah as your role model
you find it very easy and know all of
this evil and Mischief is caused by
shaytan and attribute all of this thing
to shaitaan not to that individual who
are under the influence of shaytan for
time being
so you have to really forgive this is a
really really powerful Hadith this one
if you can go ahead and elaborate on
this that the prophet saws talked about
people's Deeds being presented in before
Allah on Mondays and Thursdays and then
every slave of Allah is granted
forgiveness
and if the person didn't associate
anything with Allah in worship but the
person in whose heart there is Rancor
against his brother will not be pardoned
with regard to them it will be said hold
on to these two until they reconcile law
so I would paint a scenario like this is
like your Deeds are being presented and
now they're being rejected because you
have this Rancor and this goes back to
I'm saying okay maybe you say I forgive
him but you still hold in his Grudge not
letting go of things from the past how
Allah knows what is in your heart you
can never hide anything from Allah
if this resonates with you then you will
appreciate this hadees
and look I always encourage people and
our viewers here it's easy to listen to
the Quran and Hadith as a statement
but I would like for you to any time
from this point onwards when you hear
any references from the Quran or Hadith
try to picture
Allah having this communication with
sahaba
very loving and caring
individual who want the best for us in
this life and the year after
saying this Hadith
so that every Monday and Thursday your
Deeds are presented to Allah
picture the sahaba sitting over there
how excited
they are and look in the life of Allah
he has observed fast on Fridays and
Mondays and Thursdays and he said that
the day that my Deeds are being
presented I'd like to be in this state
of
fast that is how much cost you know
observe these things very closely and he
wanted to be in this state of fast when
his name and his deeds are being
mentioned before Allah
look at the level of belief
of being this record on submitted before
Allah
and how he is literally practicing this
caution
is saying that your Deeds are also being
presented to Allah every one of you
and we are all very excited to have this
been presented
and that should be enough to sink our
hearts
it's just like that a great big gift is
going to be given to everybody in this
Hall
all of you are not showing on the big
screen you're gonna have this price
you're going to have this price you're
going to have this price and you're
region and you're visualizing your
dreaming you're going to enjoy all of
these things and all of a sudden saying
accept
and everybody in the Hall holding their
breath and they want to know what
follows thereafter
and usually
talks like this it's a very very
important message that he wants to give
and look he sums it down to two things
one obviously have to do with our belief
second a first one believe we don't
compromise every one of us we will die
but we will not give up on Allah
but everyone of us may likely fall for
it that is to hold garages against each
other and it is very common among us and
the sort of Allah is saying that your
deeds will be held
until such time
apart from the hatred towards each other
so even is this talking about Ramadan
we're Ramadan right now so all you're
talking about all this fasting can God
go to waste ever
see remember
he is giving the importance to this
relationship mending relationship to the
degree that even your fasting your
charity has been specifically mentioned
here why because we hold our fasting
very near and dear we hold our charity
very near and dear we want to do
whatever we can to guard this rasa Allah
saying you don't get to pick and choose
with Deeds are more important to Allah
which deed is more important
you may give more value to your fasting
and charity
the more important than charity and
fasting to Allah is
your relationship there's a Hadith yeah
paraphrasing this Hadith now this is a
an authentic Hadith where the Prophet
saws do you know what is better far
better than charity praying and fasting
they said what oh messenger of Allah he
said bring it bringing those ties of
kinship together shall I inform you of
something more excellent degree than
fasting prayer and uh giving in charity
the prophet said they said yes he said
it is putting things right between
people that is the greatest virtue so do
you think now for extended family
members do you think a lot of times we
live in a culture now everyone's like
you know to each his own mind your own
business so as we conclude and come to
an end where this can motivate others to
get involved right from other uh members
of the family yes it is your own
business is the culture in America
individualism where in in Islam it's a
universal you are required
it is
upon us no individual as a Believer can
say that stay out of this no individual
as a Believer say that mind your own
business it is the business of each and
every single Muslim to make sure first
and foremost they don't hold garages
second if they find somebody holding
grudges do whatever you can through
peaceful means within your limits to
make sure that you reconcile between the
two individuals who are having issues
and Eddie trust me trust me this mind
your own business has caused Muslim
Americans so much that families are
falling apart if only Muslim have
exercised this particular Hadith of
reconciliation between the brothers and
spouses and family members and Friends
our situation would have been a lot
better than it is today our children
would have been at much more in a
healthy environment than they are today
they are confused
they're literally confused don't know
what to do and their situation like this
are forcing them to go and find
relationship elsewhere
where they're supposed to be part of
family structure of Islamic beautiful
families who is doing this individuals
who are holding grudges individuals who
are not reconciling individuals in spite
of being in a position to reconcile
between the two individuals and not
doing the Justice towards this causing
the break and falling down of the Muslim
families here in America so I encourage
first and foremost in the Blessed month
of Ramadan that please make this in this
Ramadan you will rise above your own
egos your own position and forgive for
the sake of Allah second those who are
in a position in authority to reconcile
between the two do not put off this
Noble work any longer and reconcile
between the individuals no sooner that
you come to know of two individuals
having any problem and the better sooner
the better it is the longer it waits the
difficult it is to overcome these
challenges so I urge everyone of your
out there forgive each other reconcile
your differences immediately for the
sake of Allah and if it is difficult for
you to continue to visit and meet with
this person you may distance for a while
until you really rise to the level of
really being with that person in the
same room but do not put off the process
of forgiveness any longer forgive each
other immediately as soon as possible
this is a very deep it's a blessed month
of Ramadan it is the month of the Quran
and this is uh What uh Allah talks about
you know in the Quran over and over
again and he sent the prophet of mercy
so if we want Mercy from Allah if we
want Allah to forgive our sins we have
to be more forgiving it is
49 strongly recommended in this regard
to read with the interest of time I
cannot go over but I recommend all of
our viewers to reach in detail where
Allah talk about the kinship and
Reconciliation between brothers and
sisters in Islam and Allah says you are
the word is used
the one who has been born from the same
womb
that is the close relationship gets
established when the believer says
so Eddie I pray with your efforts Allah
bring Humanity closer to Islam and bring
um
to the point where they can obey Allah
and reconcile their issues and live
their life to the fullest and become the
role model for others to follow and
first and foremost as I said you as an
individual will benefit if you are to do
this and your innocent kids will no
longer have to suffer and you will keep
the family together especially we have
come from all over the world to America
living our own relatives far and behind
over there we are creating our own
Muslim communities and we have to really
be the role model for others to follow
Islam and this can be done with the
intention of dawa just like in that
video clip that he showed it was a great
source of dawa for the humanity thank
you very much we're going over these
things thank you guys for tuning in this
is a very very important subject very
important topic and inshallah this can
be a source of motivation for us to pick
up that phone to call that loved one to
go ahead and express that Mercy that
forgiveness that God Almighty Allah
joined upon us so then we can get that
forgiveness from the almighty Creator
God Almighty Allah go ahead and hit that
notification Bell not to miss another
show when it comes out and we'll see you
next time here on the dean show until
then peace be with you assalamu alaikum
our brother in Islam Eddie from the dean
show is creating the dean Center which
is a Masjid and a dawa Center which is
going to help non-muslims learn about
Islam insha Allah and the most beautiful
thing about this is that we can all be a
part of this we can all take part in
earning rewards from this simply by
donating whatever we can to make this a
reality which is beautiful let's do that
all right let's click this link let's
donate what we can and let's make this a
reality insha Allah
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you